hello folks welcome to rational science
and today we have a great day we're
going to be talking about the electron
now
how how how deep into physics can you
get right
talking about the electron
anyways uh first of all happy new year
to all those people who are still
recovering from their hangover
and uh the question is whether it's
gonna be a happy new year
happy year
or
all right is this gonna be a terrible
year
maybe the last year
right
and so let's talk a little bit about
that let's talk a little bit about
extinction and subject matters
related to extinction
here we have a
situation that's
been happening maybe in the last two
three weeks maybe a little more
and that's the bitcoin market it's uh
looks uh
like it's in decline
and when it falls they all fall
thank you
appreciate that uh yeah uh i still don't
know what youtube did like a week ago i
still don't know what happened there but
if you can hear me
good i'm i'm glad okay uh all my
uh
things here check out right okay so
okay anyways uh bitcoin is on uh tumble
you know the whole the whole
bitcoin market the crypto market
and so the question is is this just uh
business as usual you know like this
time of the year it's always going down
and then
it picks up and ramps up and makes some
people millionaires is that what's going
to happen
or is this
an ongoing a a trend that's going to
continue
okay
and there you can see some of the uh
uh news headlines saying that bitcoin or
the crypto market is in trouble
but uh in fact uh you know for the last
day or so it's been i guess picking up
again
so i don't know you you tell me if this
has any
bearing on anything but you know the
interesting part about this is that
maybe one of the factors is this uh
country called kazakhstan
used to be one of the
uh soviet republics from the ussr
uh union of socialists
uh soviet soviet socialist republics in
fact uh we used to call them the uff sr
here at work we said the union of fewer
and fewer socialist republics because a
lot of them kept
you know uh
leaving the so-called union
and so yeah union are fewer and fewer
but apparently russia has retained a
couple and one of those is afghani um
sorry kazakhstan and turns out
kazakhstan is responsible for about
one-fifth
almost right of the
crypto mining on the planet
and uh
maybe one of the things that triggered
some of this or helped you know the
decline is the fact that you know as you
can see there they've got a little bit
of a problem political and uh economic
and maybe even military
problems over there in
kazakhstan
so much so that the russian
army had to step in to help them out you
know to weed out all the terrorists
you know how it goes uh
they have all these
uh
you know uh
like the nato they have their own nato
over there they have their union of
military and uh
intelligence and so on and so every
mafia has got their own uh
groups
and one of those uh problems right now
is this uh ukraine
and that's going to be an important
point maybe this year maybe not maybe it
just dies soon and they all reach an
agreement
but there is a possibility that you know
both sides uh neither side backs down
and instead of backing down they they go
for it right and what russia wants is
the united states to get off united
states empire because we got to talk of
these about all these regions as empires
you've got the russian empire chinese
empire the american empire period that's
it you got to talk in those terms and
russians see the
uh american empires encroaching on their
vital interests right
and so uh wants to stop them says you
know here's a red line you can't cross
that red line because if you do
uh there's gonna be trouble and you're
gonna have to fight
and
so the question is whether you know
they're gonna the americans are gonna
step over the line or not
and the americans have the other
argument they say well you know every
country has to decide on their own
whether they want to
belong to this side or that side and the
russians say no we're not going to let
ukraine fall on your side okay it's
going to be like a buffer
and uh
if
that doesn't happen then they're going
to attack ukraine and so the question is
you know everybody's got a chip on their
shoulder and they say knock it off
so we'll see what happens let's hope the
politicians the diplomats can fix this
instead of the military guys right but
anyways kazakhstan uh you know big
trouble now and maybe some of the other
uh so-called soviet republics the
russian republics now uh that are uh
part of this
you know uh military political military
organization
uh
you know maybe they're all going to have
a little bit of problems
and right now the way i see it you know
what you see there the riots is
something you know i said would happen
that and i think it's going to continue
to happen from now on you're going to
see more and more riots and more and
more cities in the world across the
planet every country is having problems
right now
that's why i can't imagine how some
people say that
bill you crazy we're gonna go extinct
this century maybe even a few decades
maybe in a few years maybe in a few
months
yeah exactly because uh you know things
are not right economically speaking
across the planet
i think all countries are suffering
right now and if you know
if you go to those countries you'll find
out what i mean every country is
undergoing some kind of problem
especially in the big cities and in the
big cities what you have is people
revolting and they're going out there
and um
and you know breaking windows
burning tires etc we're gonna see a lot
more of that as things get worse and
worse
at least that's what i think is gonna
happen okay
uh belief maybe you know i'm saying uh
the economy is gonna force people to go
out into the streets that's what i'm
saying okay continuing here fella says
you never answered my question on
whether nuclear weapons are real and do
exist in fact i did answer the question
you probably missed it i don't know you
got to check back but he said originally
nuclear weapons real or or just made up
and he talked about hiroshima and
nagasaki
were repopulated very quickly
uh implying with that that uh maybe
there was no bomb thrown out there uh on
those cities because how could it be
been repopulated immediately after the
bomb
and so my quick answer again right now
i'm not going to go through it all over
again but the quick answer was that
there was an article in the guardian
then it uh analyzed it and they said
there was a typhoon that swept through
the city
and because of that it um it kind of
washed a lot of the residual radiation
you know out into the sea that was one
issue and the other issue they raised is
that uh
the survivors many of them you know
had cancers uh throughout their lives so
yeah
but i think what's uh most interesting
about the the issue here is that there
are some people who don't believe
that the bonds were ever thrown
so what i did raise when i answered the
question i said well you know obviously
jfk never existed you know nobody
murdered him because he he wasn't there
to begin with
i mean did you see jfk did you touch him
did you see them
and so you know
do we have to test everything personally
i mean has any of you
talked to or spoke with or
shaking hands with napoleon
i mean did napoleon exist or was is this
a fairy tale that he told us how about
julius caesar any of you see him
you know so what are we going to do
we're going to say none of that ever
happened
because i didn't see it so they're
telling me a fairy tale and i just
believe it
you know and and all we can do is uh you
know just
uh carry on
the
histories from people in the past and
they pass it on to the next generation
the next generation the next generation
and we inherited it at the end of line
we inherited and you know what are you
gonna i mean you can you can say well
maybe this did not happen in the way
they told us in the way that the victors
wrote it
but that doesn't mean that some of the
people who were there
never happened never existed
and so when we take that to the
you know the nuclear bombs are we gonna
say that the bombs never fell because i
wasn't in nagasaki to you know receive
the blow
you know it's uh
again you know it's one of those things
then you got the flat earthers they they
don't believe that uh you know uh
rockets went out into space and took
pictures of the earth or the moon from
from space itself
they don't believe in that they say
because you know obviously if you take a
picture from outer space and can show
that the earth is round just by a
picture
uh you know spherical
uh that would destroy their religion and
of course they had to attack that and
say well i wasn't there to see it
i don't know that there was a satellite
that there was a rocket out there or a
camera that far out taking pictures of
the earth or the moon
and you know what can i say uh uh i have
a good solution for that you know next
time they send the um
a rocket into space from florida usually
you know the
jfk site over there kennedy center
if they're going to throw a uh
a rocket next time out into space
very simple
take your camera or ask someone from
your organization the flat earthers
there are flat earthers in miami and
florida in general right and ask him to
go in there and film the rocket with
your telescope they have all the you
know the telescopes and the
and the uh cameras everything and film
the rocket as it goes out
and tell me if that rocket goes into
outer space or comes back i mean it's
very simple that rocket keeps going and
going and going and going
it's gone
it's in outer space
so to say that rockets don't go into
outer space when you have a camera and
you have a telescope with which you can
film you know see it and film it go out
into
you know into the
beyond the
stratosphere
oh yeah i mean then
you have no no argument then you know
that we can send rockets into outer
space and of course if we can send a
rocket into outer space we can send
satellites out there and we can also
you know send
take pictures from outer space of the
earth okay so i think it's very simple
you just gotta you you like experiments
there's a chance to do your experiment
go out and
go out there and take a telescope and a
camera you know film camera or whatever
and film the rockets go into outer space
tell me that they don't go through outer
space
okay uh fella said being bred and living
as an amish is a
fitter solution than being an average
american it seems if you have ten kids
even if two or three of them have
disorders the remaining seven will be
better off
well this is not about being better off
or anything like that so this is what i
answer you know i'm saying that this has
nothing to do with better or worse it
has nothing to do with being better off
uh opinions are not part of science okay
many envy the lives of the amish but
that's irrelevant okay so you know i i
think they have a great life and that
doesn't even come into play the issue
here is inbreeding leads to mentally
physically
handicapped kids that's what it is okay
so
the problem is inbreeding
leads to problems genetic problems which
can
manifest themselves either as
physical or mental problems and so one
generation or a few kids of that
generation will come out bad okay and i
think that's a microcosm of what's
happened to humanity we've been
inbreeding now for who knows how many
thousands of years okay
and uh
so
you know right now we're having problems
we're having uh
physical and mental problems uh the
physical ones that we've never seen
before mental ones probably as well
so you figure out if that's got any
bearing on uh procreation
okay
and again the amnesia just an example
and i'm just using them as an analogy
what is happening to the human race as a
whole okay
okay let me move on here
uh
fella says
if i can get it up here
well it says a theory has experiments
that are repeatable with consistent
observations that are peer-reviewed
whoa
this last generation on earth bs is
based on nothing but opinion pure
speculation prediction prophecy
well first of all theory has no
experiments theory means you're going to
give an explanation that's what a theory
is it's an explanation in physics as an
explanation of a mechanism that's what
we're talking about here so
you know
we need no experiments to give you an
explanation
explanation is separate from an
experiment you can do all the
experiments you want at home
learn whatever you want take all the
data you want reach your own conclusions
but when you come to the conference all
we want is the explanation the mechanism
what you learn what you what you can
explain
we don't want you doing an experiment
out there in front of us and saying
here's the experiment i did who cares
what experiment you did
and then the other issue is you know
that we cannot experiment on extinction
so here's here's my answer to this fella
okay
i can't run an experiment on human
extinction i mean what are we going to
do
kill all humans and say well you were
right bill you know
humans did become extinct
i mean i don't know what experiment
you're going to run on human extinction
and then peer reviewed by whom who's
going to appear to be the the pope uh
maybe the dalai lama who who's going to
be doing the uh
this peer review
uh maybe some mathematician who talks
about space-time uh four-dimensional
space-time maybe about zero dimensional
uh singularities is or a particle being
at two places at once
uh is is that who we're gonna is that
who's gonna peer review the your paper
and then you know opinion again is not a
theory okay prediction is a description
and prediction is not an explanation
uh what we're talking about is a full
and foolproof mechanism
and mechanism has nothing to do with
prediction okay so
again
his um his attack is misplaced
completely okay what we're talking about
here is a mechanism what is a mechanism
that's gonna cause the extinction of man
one and second
a mechanism man can't do anything about
i mean that's the crucial part because
if you can do something about whatever's
coming whatever's going to cause the
extinction of man well then you know uh
what you're talking about here is you
know uh
essentially something you could do
something about maybe you can overcome
it
but if there's something you can't do
anything about
now
that's that's a guaranteed you know
mechanism of extinction and that's what
we're presenting here we're saying that
there is a guaranteed mechanism of
extinction
okay that's different than the asteroid
theory and the
all the uh the other theory about the
neanderthal disappearing because they
made it with humans you know all those
theories very simple you know we have no
one to mate with now so
we're not gonna die because we don't
have any neanderthals or any cousins of
any kind to interbreed with
and uh asteroid hopefully we can do
something about it i mean if an asteroid
comes our way
it's no biggie you know we blow it up
maybe with a with a nuke
so that means we're gonna live forever
because we can take care of those
problems
well maybe those weren't the mechanisms
that caused those extinctions maybe
that's the better conclusion
okay so this is the the issue
okay another issue raised by another
fellow the rich have vast underground
cities
okay uh and and you know about this they
showed them to you you've been through
all those uh
go for holes you know
you know where the kitchen is you know
you've seen it oh they gave you a tour
i mean how do you know they're the best
underground cities
okay i mean if you know of one very very
simple you just dig
with your drill
somewhere and maybe you'll get down
there maybe you you can have your
underground city
yeah i mean uh people have speculation
they say oh the rich have all these
things maybe that's what you would do if
you know if you
had the money you would say oh i'm going
to build my underground city my personal
underground city but let me tell you
something about that let's assume let's
assume the gates and the buffets and all
these uh
people out there
you know they they have all the all
these underground cities these gopher
holes in which they can hide if
uh worst comes to worst okay
so
the question is how are they going to
live there i mean are they going to have
servants
serving them
are they going to take people
down there who are going to protect them
while the world is in turmoil
and the question is can they trust them
can they trust these people i mean right
now all these people work for people
like gates right bill gates my brother
he's got a little more money than me
and they work for them
for money
but you know you take the money out of
the picture
why does joe blow who works for bill
gates have to
follow any orders or serve his master
anymore what's he gonna do pay him with
money
fire him maybe
so the problem with all this
underground cities notion is that if you
create your underground city
you know you're the first one they're
gonna roast on the barbecue
because you know you're probably old
that's why you have money in general
terms right and
all these young people who are
protecting you who are doing the leg and
work
laying arm work for you they don't have
to follow your orders afterwards
once the economy falls apart that's it
you know you're
there's nothing you can bribe them with
you can give them
a pound of gold and they can't do
anything with it they're gonna throw it
away they say what do i need this rock
for
see all that stuff is important now
today
but after the world collapses there's
nowhere to hide okay so all these
underground cities speculation is just
people who are
dreaming about stuff uh from hollywood
you know they're saying oh an
underground city how cool that would be
to have one uh i'm gonna if i were rich
that's what i would do put a underground
city
yeah you're gonna hide in there sure but
you're going to hide alone because no
one else is going to follow you and
whoever follows you there you better
have a lot of confidence a lot of faith
in them right
you surely don't want to
rely on them through salaries
you don't want uh proletarians down
there okay people who depend on a salary
because
once money is no more they have no
reason to you know to follow your orders
or even your recommendations in fact
they say hey i don't need you anymore
okay so keep that in mind
it's not a question making underground
cities it's a question of how do you
survive an extinction as much as you can
if possible right
okay if that says afghanistan has the
world's largest store of rare earth
minerals mined by the usa and now taken
over by china tradition
uh yeah see the the issue
this came
uh around because i said that you know
the united states is guarding taiwan
because taiwan has taiwan semiconductor
and there's two things involved there
one is that it's probably the largest if
not one of the largest in the world as
far as what is known as a foundry uh
manufacturer of chips actual
manufacturer chips
that means that you know suddenly if you
can get a hold of that prize
uh you can stop the flow with chips
maybe to the west okay
and uh you know you got the control of
the faucet okay
and so this is a problem fishing now
that there
there is a you know dearth of um chips
in the world especially in the
automotive industry
imagine if china where i get what if
they get a hold of
you know taiwan seminar there would be
fewer chips out in the world
if china so desires okay that's one
issue the other one is that you know
china is behind the the west maybe five
to eight years in chip development and
chip design and
and manufacturing and so on
can you imagine if they get a hold of
taiwan semiconductor
suddenly you know they they gain five to
eight years
and you know come up to speed with the
rest of the world western world right
so suddenly you have all this technology
in their hands
so that's important for china and that
would be important for the united states
and i think that that's why the united
states tries to protect taiwan primarily
because that's the key prize in taiwan
taiwan's semiconductor keep that in mind
okay i'm telling you because i work in
the industry i know how important i one
semiconductor is
manufacturing is for the world
it's a very important company it's a big
company by the way okay a lot of uh
companies subcontract to taiwan
semiconductor
but what's the issue the issue here he's
saying you know i said you know they
abandoned afghanistan because there was
no taiwan semiconductor in afghanistan
meaning you know there's nothing real of
very important in in afghanistan so so
the guy says well there is they have all
this uh mining
yeah you have to develop it that's one
issue and you can't develop in while you
have a war
and you have china and russia they're
helping afghanistan to make sure the
united states is not successful in
afghanistan they've done this for many
years
you know the afghanis the the one the
guys in the mountains you know the
hillbillies
you know they get their weapons where
they get them they get them from russia
and they get them from china these
countries are helping the enemy of my
enemy is my friend you know
and so um
so the united states realized that
they're spending a lot of money they're
not getting a big bang for the buck and
they said we better invest somewhere
else and they decided to move their
forces to the east
farther east you know and so now they're
in the east they're making an
arrangement with australia with the uk
right and they're trying to protect
taiwan and australia right and they're
trying to protect taiwan because they
realize that
protecting taiwan is a little more
important than protecting afghanistan
besides it's probably easier right now
to protect taiwan to a certain degree
than it is to protect afghanistan which
is closer to both china and russia
right and these countries will be
helping afghanistan until the united
states
bogs down and can't get out of there
it's another vietnam and so they
realized this and they said no let's get
out of afghanistan it's not worth it
let's go and protect instead let's put
our resources in taiwan and that's i
think the strategy now okay so that's
what uh the answer is to this so yeah
even though thai
afghanistan has mining and so on
minerals
uh you gotta you gotta mine them and you
can't
mine with one shovel and on the other
hand hold a machine gun you know fight
you know what do you uh
uh what do you what are these um
i call them uh
uh forget the name now the
the greek uh
guy who worked both in the farm and also
had to you know
uh carry a weapon you know he he did
both and so so are these guys you know
you can't you can't on the one hand mine
and the other one hold a machine gun and
protect yourself okay
okay another issue here foul says as for
human beings being unable to travel to
the stars light years away you claim all
atoms are connected but how but the how
the physical mechanism is yet to be
explained
okay uh i don't know what the mechanism
is talking about yeah they're connected
that's not an explanation they're just
it's just an assumption okay is it
possible if a physical mechanism exists
that involves torsion rather than
movement of electrons as you propose
traveling faster than the speed of light
may be possible well the issue there is
that you know you get a rope like my
famous rope here okay
and you know you can torque it all you
want right
but the rope goes nowhere the link
goes nowhere maybe a little that way
maybe a little bit that way but that's
it you know there's no motion
that the the link is not traveling
you're not the speed of light
well what travels is this signal along
the rope which causes pressure or a
little impulse
at the end of the rope okay against the
atom to which it's connected
and so you know
matter
are atoms atoms are not the ones
traveling at the speed of light okay you
know when i move i don't move at the
speed of light through the ropes
light moves along the ropes to my eyes
to all my atoms at the speed of light
meaning the torsion
reach that signal reaches me at the
speed of light but the atoms they move
very slowly or
depending on what you know what it
belongs to in my case i move very slowly
so to say that because the torsion
travels at the speed of light that the
atoms travel at the speed of light we're
gonna make it to the nearest star
absolutely not okay there's there's no
way you're gonna achieve that so the the
point here is that we cannot leave the
planet
uh meaning we cannot go to the nearest
star
and like i said the other day we don't
even need to
go to the nearest star
because we've got enough room here on
earth
we've got more than enough room
and the problem there is that we're not
producing children you know the growth
rate is going down and so because we're
not producing children we have enough
room for all the people that we are and
that we will make in the next few years
or until we
we become extinct and so we don't have
to worry about uh space like going into
mars or the moon and creating stations
because you know the planet is
overcrowded no such thing
the overcrowdedness is only in the
cities okay
other than that the planet is empty
you know and i made the numbers the
other day about how empty it is so no
we're not we don't need to travel we
don't need to go to another planet or
star system or moon or whatever or or
asteroid uh because because of reasons
of space
that we don't have a problem of space
here on on the planet okay we have
enough room for everybody so don't worry
about space we got a different problem
and that's that we're not producing
children to fill the spaces that we do
have okay that's the problem
okay um
last point here fella says is the lack
of genetic diversity in the human gene
pool why no one is immune from being
infected with a single virus
again uh you know this is the notion
that the geneticists have that it's got
to do with not with what i say it's got
to do with meaning that inbreeding leads
to loss of genetic diversity
and loss of genetic diversity leads to
problem children
okay that's that's my argument these
people talk about something else the
fact that we are if we have all the same
genetic code
like we're all exact clones of each
other then the problem there is that a
single disease can kill us all because
none of us have any defenses against
that virus or bacteria or whatever so
i'm saying that
i'm not worried about that because
humans are not going to die because of
disease
okay like no animal in the past ever
died of no species in the past became
extinct because of disease now if we're
going to die we're going to die for
something else and i'm saying it's going
to be the economy but meanwhile what we
do have is that we have inbreeding at
the end of our life
our species life and that inbreeding is
producing bad children so if you see
lousy children out there today
children with handicaps of all kinds
physical and
mental i'm saying that's due to
inbreeding and to loss of genetic
diversity okay but anyways he said this
slow-moving disaster has been evident
studying and preparations are underway
to create more human
genetic diversity mutations and hybrids
we're creating more genetic diversity
how are we doing that okay i mean we
have a little machine or what
people having fewer children may be
addressed by the official by the
artificial womb
we're gonna have a little robot you know
uh
producing children no nobody's gonna do
that nobody's gonna produce children in
artificial wombs where did you get this
people
are talking about robots about androids
about they got too much hollywood in
their heads maybe too many games this is
not
realistic i mean what are you going to
do i mean are we going to produce
children in in a factory like an
assembly line we're going to uh put
carbon in and nitrogen oxygen whatever
and produce children out of the
you know coming out of the assembly line
for what who's gonna produce children
for what what what's the economic
advantage for a company to produce
children
i mean let's assume we we learn how to
do it okay god gives us the the
knowledge the the mechanism we say okay
we start here we put all the ingredients
and out here comes a child so we don't
need women anymore right we can produce
it on the assembly line
i mean first of all it's crazy but let's
assume let's go crazy let's let's make
sure we all agree that's that is
feasible let's do the thought experiment
why would anyone produce children
i mean are you going to sell children on
the market and say oh we're going to
sell children whoever wants them there's
so many parents out there that want
children you know adopt children
if that were so you know you wouldn't
have foster homes
so the fellow says you know the
mechanism of reproduction is not a
mystery i guess it is for you
so uh no i don't think we're gonna be
producing children because no one is
gonna get into the business of producing
children right now we're all in a
different business and the business
that's growing tremendously is the
internet business everybody's going on
the internet
nobody wants to work everybody just
wants to hit it big and in that sense
you know we've changed the
ethics the way of thinking of previous
generations you know a lot of people in
the past what they wanted is to
you know get a good job have a family
etc you know children
that's gone now people think in general
it's it's disappearing what people want
now is just to hit it big
so that in fact they don't want kids
because kids tie them down and they just
want to do careers
and have enjoy life you know have
servants maybe uh have a palace uh be by
the beach
have your own yacht
that's what everybody dreams about or a
lot of people dream about the new
generations and so nobody's thinking
about having kids and having family and
10 children you know who's thinking
about that
where will you find someone who says i
want to have 10 children i want to have
big family here like the old days
very very few people if anyone
anyways
so much for
extinction
let's move on to the subject matter of
today physics and what is that about
well we're going to be talking about uh
the electron but before we can get to
the electron why don't we start at the
scientific method we've got something so
fundamentally wrong about the uh
scientific method and here's an example
you know it's uh from this organization
i just found it random not that i look
for but i found about random here's what
they say okay puts in everything in the
proper
light
or
organization for autism
research
and it says when confronted with claims
that are presented as true such as that
doctors believe how can we make a
reasonable evaluation to a certain as
confidently as possible whether the
claim has merit
claims abound from alien abductions and
the existence of loch ness
to eating wild boar meat to cure
autism
how can we separate the wheat from the
staff in a way that both prevents the
acceptance of wildly suspicious claims
that have no support and permits
adoption with some level of certainty
and comfort of claims that are likely to
in fact be true
the best way we
the best way known to evaluate claims is
to adopt the intellectual discipline of
science and the scientific method of
investigation
okay let's see what that's all about
says this methodology involves carefully
defining terms
which no one in mathematics does know
when biology does we don't have a
definition for life yet no one in
paleontology does we don't have a
definition of what a mass ex
mass extinction and background
extinction are and for sure we have no
definitions at all in mathematical
physics not one not one that we can sink
our teeth in so i don't know what this
involves carefully defining terms means
or what they're talking about
they continue conducting controlled
experiments when possible why do we need
to con conduct an experiment to give an
explanation i mean if you want to
conduct an experiment go ahead but
what's that got to do with science
science is the explanation not the not
doing experiments
practicing the law of parasimony and
adopting philosophic doubt or skepticism
skepticism doubt is that science i mean
you can doubt all you want but that's
got to do with belief with religion not
with
explanation okay although all the
methods of science are important
practicing skepticism is crucial to
protecting oneself from believing
unsubstantiated claims
yeah you're talking about belief you're
not talking about explaining rationally
and objectively so again people have
this notion that science is about belief
that it's got to do with proof we're
presenting evidence with doing
experiments to present evidence so that
you can prove so that you can convince
and convert
the jury
that's not science that's called
religion that's called belief
okay that's opinion
right now uh people are mistaken if they
think that's the scientific method
no science is not about belief okay
that's mathematics the mathematical
physics that's about belief you know
they give you a rotten explanation and
idiotic explanation they say believe it
why should i believe it well because we
did the test we did the experiment we
proved it here's the equation
we have repeatable
experiments we can predict what's going
to happen and therefore we know
and you say well hold it okay you did
all that
and you're telling me that a particle
can be at two places at once that's your
explanation or you're telling me the
earth drags space-time four-dimensional
space-time around itself
those are the conclusions those are the
theories you want me to believe in that
okay so we have a problem yeah
science is not about belief okay that's
only in mathematics that's where they
talk about belief and proof and evidence
and running experiments in sense we
don't do that science specifically in
physics we talk about explanation you
have to have an objective explanation
for how something works in the invisible
world of mother natures out there
okay
so here we have a couple of altar boys
and
you know these uh choir boys that go to
college and they get their phds why do
they get their phds because they suck up
essentially that's what it amounts to in
other words how do you get a phd well
for that you have to have an advisor
and you better follow the rules of the
advisor because otherwise he's not going
to advise you
okay he's not going to be your
supervisor so you better more or less be
in line with what he already believes
and so whatever
paper you're going to write about
whatever your phd is going to be about
you're going to write whatever he told
you or more or less it's going to be in
line with your supervisor
and what this guarantees is that from
generation to generation to degeneration
what we have is
all these people learning the same thing
and just going on a single tangent
okay
so if you get it wrong from the start
you get it wrong from niels bohr or from
albert einstein well the next generation
gets it wrong from them because they
have to bow down to einstein and boar
and what about the next generation well
they get it wrong from from those who
got it wrong from einstein and bourne so
on down the line
and so yeah here you have these uh this
group of uh
choir boys you know i think you
recognize some of them
and uh and these are the ones who follow
and just repeat
what they learned by rote
so they had to learn by road in order to
get their phds otherwise they wouldn't
have gotten their phds
and
you know once they got their phds all
they can do is just make a career out of
it and hopefully get into like these
folks do get into the
limelight you know get it out there so
that people see them and go on
television you know do some hollywood
stuff
and that makes them more famous they
make a lot of money
and what do they talk about they talk
about about the same nonsense that
everybody else does
and they talk about the same nonsense
that they inherited from their
forefathers
whom they learned from by wrote and who
did their forefathers learn from they
learned it by road from the previous
generation down the line and down the
line and down the line and that's all we
have right now okay and so
we're not going to get any new ideas if
all these people are just repeating
what their uh phd uh supervisors
uh approve
okay and coach them on that's the issue
and so what do these people believe in
what are the you know what's what are
the main points that you see out there
that that these choir boys repeat by you
know
by wrote they repeat it as parents but
like if they memorize the poetry and
these are some examples here okay the
black hole singularity okay everybody
talks about those that's a big subject
today big bang lots of people
investigating that okay
uh
then you have transfer of energy there
you know transfer of info information so
we're transferring concepts okay all
these ghosts and spirits that they
transfer around concepts that they turn
into objects
particles at two places at once you know
there you have the covid you know bug
it's two places at once i guess right
uh
way particle duality you know you can't
even imagine this thing that turns into
what is known as a wave packet no one
can draw it
one tribe there it's a little arrow with
a kerdi-cue around it
that's by the way from uh
what's his name roger penrose
that's how he visualizes the wave packet
whatever that is that little curlicue i
mean what's that era i mean
light has a little arrow at the end of
it is is that what it what
light looks like
i mean all these people have to be
kidding me okay and so yeah they all
they do is just keep
repeating what the previous generation
fed to them and so you know a lot of
these phds you wonder
you know what do they know they know
equations yeah because that's something
you repeat you can do the equation you
understand it just by looking at the
variables there no problem
that's a language
but from there to extrapolate that now
you can understand how the universe
works meaning the explanation of the
mechanisms
well that's a
big step for mankind okay
okay so
i think they're stretching uh their
their research a little too far
okay so uh here we have uh file says
along those same lines says energy
definition is capacity to do work
uh-huh capacity to do work okay so
therefore it is not a stand-alone object
right because you're saying it's
capacity we can't say that energy is a
physical object because if energy is
capacity
obviously there's no physical object
called capacity okay
and so it's not a standalone object
either under the c touch definition of
mathematical
physics because if an object is that
which you can see touch hopefully you
cannot see or touch capacity because
it's a concept
so even under the mathematical
definition uh energy is not a physical
object and obviously it's not under
science okay because uh under science
it's a
shape an object is that which has shape
and so you don't energy neither energy
nor capacity has shape so
it bumps out under both definitions as
an object okay so let's make sure we we
cover that you know dot that i and then
cross that t right cover that base
and uh
then so it's an irrational to say that
we're gonna transfer capacity okay
because what is capacity well there you
have the definition amount that
something can contain or produce ability
to contain amount in or number that can
be contained
okay so uh
that's what capacity is it represents a
concept talking about quantities okay
and so yeah uh we cannot say that energy
if energy is capacity that energy is a
physical object so we cannot talk about
transferring energy which is
a famous phrase of mathematical physics
they say oh we're going to transfer
capacity
transfer energy transfer information
yeah how do you transfer information
how you carry it with your hands does it
drip through your fingers i mean how do
you do it with information
and along with saying lionfell says a
field is an interaction of energy with
materials
now if energy is capacity and capacity
is not a physical object meaning energy
is not a physical object how can it
interact with anything
i mean what do we have interaction of uh
concepts we have love hitting
intelligence is that what we have here
one hitting the other one
i mean what do you mean interaction of
energy with materials meaning matter
meaning things i guess right i'm
assuming that's what it means by
material okay
and uh so here's my answer to that again
leading to
where we're headed right
field is not a thing so it's a quantity
represented by a number that has a value
for each point in space and time
so no a field you know let's put his
definition here field is an interaction
he says
uh of energy no that's not what a field
is and uh he should look up the
definition he'll find it uh this one
comes from the wikipedia but you'll find
almost the same definition everywhere
out there and what you find is that yeah
it's a quantity that's what a field is
it's a bunch of numbers of value at each
point in space and time
as defined by mathematical physics and
when you look up each one of those
numbers there you uh each one of those
words there like number value point and
space and time well you find those
definitions none of which are
none of them are a single not a single
one of them is a number a is a is an
object it's a thing okay they're all
concepts and so field is a concept and
again if it's a quantity of whatever
then it's got to be a concept okay so
you cannot say that you know that
you're going to have a field that does
this and does that you can't treat field
as a physical object because obviously
field is an abstract mathematical
concept there is no physical standalone
object called field but these people
have been brainwashed so much by uh
mathematical physics when they were
first in high school maybe in college
and they just keep repeating oh energy
we transfer energy oh feel that the
field is shaking is vibrating it's it's
excited it's the excited field there's
no such thing these are uh euphemisms
figures of speech
you can't use those to do
physical mechanisms in physics
to explain objectively a mechanism like
you would explain how a car works or or
how a scooter runs or whatever okay you
can't do that with you can't use these
words to explain a mechanism that's the
issue
okay um
and it thought continues he says mass is
a measure how many atoms
uh and okay and then he says we use
scales
meaning to measure i put that in there
the two measure okay
therefore mass result should be
specified in number of atoms right
okay because if the mass is a measure of
how many atoms okay then uh
either it's a measure or the number of
atoms
one of the two it can't be both okay so
either mass is a
how many atoms in which case you get a
specified in number of atoms meaning
that there you have an example uh if you
have a mass of one trillion atoms then
then you could say yeah this has a mass
of one trillion atoms you can't say it
has one kilogram
because one kilogram is not the same
thing as a million atoms or a trillion
atoms or whatever you know you got to
specify the the result your value your
your your your ending
thing uh for mass as a number you gotta
say 10 atoms five atoms 500 atoms a
trillion atoms or whatever that's how
you have to specify mass you can't say
it's a kilogram because that's weight
and you say well that's an ordinary
speech notion of of weight well again
what did you do you put it on the scale
that's what you did
but to count atoms you don't need to put
them on a scale what you need is just an
abacus you don't you don't put them on a
scale
okay so this is how simple it is either
mass is the quantity of matter
or it's a measure of a quantity of
matter but if it's a measure of quantity
of matter you're talking about weight
because now you're saying how much each
atom weighs you're going to weigh the
thing on a scale like you say there if
you put it on a scale now you're
measuring its weight
okay so a kilogram is a weight
not only
in ordinary speech it's also for
mathematical physics okay because what
you're doing is you're gonna
you're gonna state your your
value your final result you're gonna
state 1 trillion atoms you're going to
say that's one kilogram no one kilogram
is the pull of gravity on that on those
trillion atoms that's what uh
that's what you measure there with a
scale so if you put it on a scale you're
measuring the weight
okay and you can't say well weight is
something else because it weighs
different on the moon yeah because the
attraction of gravity on the moon over
each one of those particles is different
that's the only reason okay but
otherwise uh mass has nothing to do with
it mass is the quantity of atoms
stated in quantity of atoms say 1
trillion atoms very simple all you got
to do is use an abacus not a scale
very simple
and mass is not an object according to
the c touch criteria of mathematical
physics remember because if if if you're
going to talk about
whether you measure or whether you know
you weigh it or you count atoms either
way if mass is either one of those two
mass is not a physical object because
you're not talking about the object per
se you're talking about how much it
weighs
or how many atoms you counted
neither one of those qualifies as a
physical object standalone physical
object and certainly you can't touch
quantity if that's what uh mass is a
quantity right you can't touch the
number five okay
well that one you can't
but i mean you know the number five
represents a concept an abstract concept
mathematical concept you can't touch
abstract mathematical concepts i can't
touch threes five fours
i can't touch numbers
okay you can only touch it when you put
it on the
on the paper and then you're touching
the paper and the ink
and so mass is not an object according
to that it's also not according to
the definition of science which is that
which has shape
a definition that destroys all religions
okay and people of course religious
people are very upset about that they
don't like
you
destroying their religion so they fight
it you know with tooth and nail because
they realize their religious is on the
rock on the rocks
okay let's move on here and uh here we
have
who says again leading to what we're
going to get to which is the electron
okay all this has to do with it uh here
we have what is resistance the fall says
this is in relation to what i talked
about the other day
a measure of the amount of work this is
what he says
required to transfer electrical energy
through a medium
my god how do you transfer energy
through any medium if energy is not a
physical object like we just stated okay
so they have this ghost this spirit
which is
a
concept that they turn into an object
and they talk about transferring energy
through a medium i mean through water
through space is space a medium or maybe
it's a non-medium
and they're going to transfer this
energy whatever that is which is a
concept
so so they start off on the wrong foot
because they're using the wrong language
they have to get away from the
mathematical language you can't use
field you can't use the word energy you
can't use the word mass not in science
okay that's in religion you can use
those words okay not in physics
okay and so question he says is the
resistance in a vacuum proportional to
the distance between the anode and
cathode aha so we're going to concede
that we have this thing called energy
and he's going to talk about the
resistance
in the vacuum that the energy whatever i
guess he's talking about the electrons
which is what i talked about the other
day because we're talking about
resistance resistant to what to electron
flow
okay so he's saying is there a
resistance in the vacuum
okay
and he says this a question of distance
okay a lot of people have this in the
back of their minds that maybe it's got
to do with distance because
if you you turn on the the pressure or
the
the the flow whatever then you have
these electrons flowing through space
and they might reach the the anode
right so you have the these little
electrum balls think of them as electron
balls right
uh corpuscles they're flying through the
air or through the vacuum okay there's
no resistance there they're flying
through the vacuum
and
they don't go that far because they fall
before they reach
you know the the other shore
but if you hit them harder enough you
know then maybe they do reach the
uh anode meaning that
they were able to
reach the other shore but
it's a question of distance because the
farther you got it the more you have to
push him to reach that point that's what
he's saying this is his logic and a lot
of people have the same logic they're
saying oh you have to push the electrons
harder in order for the electron to
reach the cathode that's all you got to
do in a vacuum
okay
that's that's the
setup okay what these people are
thinking okay if so how how is
long-distance communication through
space affected by resistance not just by
the inverse square law okay
and he does uh say that you know is
there uh
is the resistance in a vacuum
proportional to the distance between the
anode and the cathode
okay listen this is an important
question okay because a lot of people i
think think in these same terms okay
they they're thinking oh it's so far
away you just need to push it harder so
let's go in steps here to find out
what's happening to the electrons okay
as they go through the vacuum because
that's the issue that's how
quantum visualizes this quantum has
gotten rid of the atom it just does
electricity with electrons and so does
the electric universe by the way you
know they say oh we have all this
electron the electron flow that's
electricity so they got rid of the atom
they're not even paying attention to the
atom anymore they're not thinking that
there's a row of atoms
from here to the other galaxy through
which the electrons travel from atom to
atom they're not thinking about that
they're saying oh the electron beads
just fly to the other side
okay no no atoms in between there's no
bridge
okay it's just the electrons just flying
through the vacuum that's the notion all
these people have okay let's get that
right
okay and so here we have uh essentially
that setup we're saying okay here we
have the electrons
and they're moving from one uh terminal
to the other okay from
cathode to anode we're just going to go
with this
flow okay
and so the question is whether if that's
vacuum total vacuum that we have there
that black stuff
that means there's nothing there
what is vacuum vacuum is the absence of
an object in other words vacuum is that
which has no shape
so we have absolutely nothing there the
only objects there are the ones you see
the yellow ones those are the electron
beads
okay they're coming out of the atoms and
somehow flowing and we call this flow of
electrons we're going to call that
electricity
does electricity flow through the vacuum
without any atoms in between
that's the question
or do we have to have atoms
though the electrons have to go from
atom to atom
okay so we have a difference between
these two scenarios here you have atoms
so you have the electrons going from
atom to atom in the conduction uh
zone okay and here you have them without
the atoms they just go through the
vacuum without any need
for a bridge for anything
through which uh
they can you know jump from one atom to
the next okay so these are the two
scenarios and the question is can we do
electricity in the vacuum total vacuum
just sending electron beads discrete
electron beads remember the beads are
not tied to one another
okay and so these beads for some reason
are pushed like from a cannon okay and
so the beads are going
it's like a machine gun shooting bullets
and so the bullets are going one right
behind the other they're all individual
one is not tied to the other that means
if you move your gun
the the spray the the bullets are gonna
be like a um
you know like uh
if if you move your hose
right with the water squirting out
they're gonna describe a curve
if you move your machine gun the bullets
are not gonna go straight only if you
keep that machine gun perfectly straight
will the bullets go one right after
another you can say but if you're going
to move that machine gun the bullets are
going to you know have a um
a curve they're going to describe a curb
okay so keep those two things in mind
okay
but here we have
a situation we have cannonball man okay
cannonball man he wants to reach the
other shore
okay but it turns out he's not uh he's
not gonna
power his um his cannon
strong enough so the cannon shoots him
but it's not strong enough so he ends up
in the water okay so he doesn't end up
on the other shore why because the
cannon is not powerful enough or doesn't
have the uh power the might
it doesn't uh
really
create such an impulse on him to to make
it to the other shore so how do we reach
the other shore well we have to increase
the power or the impulse right so now
the guy
puts a little more power in there now he
can reach the other shore okay great
okay so now we made it to the other
shore why because
the cannon is pushing him
but people have to understand that in
this scenario you have two issues one is
gravity
and the other one is uh friction you
have the friction with the air and with
anything else that might be in the air
okay but specif specifically the air and
then you have gravity but see where the
scenario we were discussing just now
was in outer space where there's
absolutely nothing
so if if i'm going to shoot electrons
right if i'm going to let me get rid of
this one
if i'm going to shoot electrons out of
my canon
and i'm going to shoot them in outer
space
where there's nothing
between two galaxies for example there's
nothing there in between
okay
the electrons have nothing to
stop them
because there's nothing there to stop
them so that electron can go all the way
to the other side of the universe if it
wants to
unless gravity or some object interferes
with their trajectory so if we have two
galaxies we have total empty space
that electron should reach the other
side should we should have electricity
across the universe because all we're
sending is the electron we don't need
any atoms remember that according to
quantum mechanics and the electric
universe we can send those electrons
and
and it's not a question how much force
the cannon
has
you can you can tip it like that if you
want
that electron
once it starts rolling there's nothing
to stop it
why would it stop
why would you need to
give it more push
if there's nothing that's causing
friction on that electron and there's no
gravity other than maybe your little gun
let's assume you're in the middle of
space you shoot that electron right
well you know you don't have enough
gravity to pull it back and so that
thing is going to go in fact it might
even be pulled from the front from a
galaxy which has a little more influence
than you who are out there you know in
the middle of nowhere
so that electron should go to the galaxy
it doesn't matter if you hit it with a
paddle or you just tip it with your
little finger it's going to roll all the
way to the other side because there's
nothing to stop it
so in a vacuum
if quantum mechanics is correct if
electric universe are correct you know
an electron should
should not be stopped by anything no
friction no gravity and that electron
should just go on and on and on and on
and it doesn't need a bigger cannon to
shoot it across the
river you know from one bank to another
that's my argument okay so here we have
it here let's illustrate that so that
you are aware
illustrate that what i'm talking about
here you have one galaxy and you're in
the middle of space you're far away from
the two galaxies but you're just going
to shoot with whatever you've got there
a little
cathode and you're going to shoot it to
the anode which is on the other side
those electron beads are going to move
through space because there's nothing to
stop it
so you don't need more power you don't
need more voltage or anything like that
all you need is a big cannon or even not
even a big canon you can hit one
electron bead with your little tip of
your finger and it should reach the
other end without any problem because
that's what electricity is the flow of
electron beads you have nothing to stop
the electron bead so it should go all
the way to the other side
period
okay is that the case well obviously not
you know we know
i mean anyone who's worked in the
industry that if you put um
uh
you know if you have a vacuum and again
i talked about
i worked in uh minus seven torr range
which is high vacuum okay i've been
seeing up to uh minus eight range
we didn't work at that level because
it's too much uh time pumping the system
and you don't need that kind of vacuum
for the work that i did you know
semiconductors but we were typically in
the five to the minus seven range tor
right range
and that's high vacuum and when you have
high vacuum you know
that is quite clean whatever whatever
electrons you shoot right have very
little to bounce again to recombine and
they reach the other side suppose in
other words there's electricity there
okay
and you have this plasma okay and so
you're shooting through this plasma
essentially
and so you have electricity but if you
pump it down to five to the minus seven
well you know you don't have enough uh
current there to
to um create
to create a connection you don't have
current and what happens you have to
fill the vacuum chamber again with
platinum with
we did it with argon so that now you
have some material with which to do what
we did with sputtering or
what we called uh
iron implantation
so now you have some material in there
you have atoms
and you can have a current but if you
remove all the all this
uh gas out of the system you remove all
the water all the oxygen anything that's
in there
and you pump it down to five to minus
seven you don't have a curve
you do not have a current five to the
minus seven
uh torn you say well maybe you you gotta
shoot it harder
you gotta have a bigger cannon
it's not a question of the canon
it's a it's a question of how much
material you have inside the system
and for that you need a connection you
need the bridge
for that electron to move if you're
going to talk about electron beads you
need a bridge
you cannot do electricity without a
bridge
that's the issue
and yeah we do have a bridge and i
showed it the other day that we have the
uh all
electron shells that are merged then you
have a bridge because what you're not
sending a little bead
adam to adam now what you do is you have
a torsion in situ that's what you have
that's electricity
anyways
what's interesting is the electric
universe one of the groups that loves to
talk about electricity but never defined
it you know here this is what they think
of uh
the universe they think it's all these
filaments that are connected that are
connecting all the stars and everything
and they say oh all that's electricity
which is binding all the stars
and
and the universe as a whole and so they
call them filaments but see what you're
staring at according to them is
electricity flowing through there but
the problem is they're going to do this
electricity with discrete beads
and one of the issues there is whether
this is alternating current or direct
current that's one issue you should ask
the
the famous uh electricians of the
electric universe i mean is electricity
flowing only in one direction from anode
to cathode which star is the cathode
which one's the anode that's one issue
and then the other issue is uh you know
all these discrete beads the electron
beads with which they work you know uh
they're not tied to each other why would
one follow the other one why would one
bead follow the the other one
you know why don't they uh swerve in
space i mean after all all this uh all
these stars all these galaxies they're
all in motion so you know all these
beads should be describing arcs and uh
in space they should be moving in um in
curves
okay
and here's another vision of their uh
uh filament universe
and they love this stuff because they
say oh see this proves that electricity
does flow from one galaxy to another and
so they show you this stuff and and they
try to convince you through visual
effects that this is exactly what the
universe is it's just a bunch of
electricity flowing through these
filaments
and that's what they believe in okay
that's the world we have out there in
the so-called mathematical science world
okay um one follower asks he says this
is takes us into the subject matter also
using your drill analogy okay
uh would the following be true speed of
the drill bit voltage uh
spinning in one direction direct voltage
spinning in one direction than the other
alternating voltage size of the drill
bit current more electron shell spinning
well the problem is
you're confusing voltage with current
with electricity okay voltage is not
really electricity is one aspect of
electricity electricity is supposedly
the flow of
beads in the case of quantum mechanics
which again is not voltage and in the
case of the rope model again we have
torsion of the uh
bound electron shells which we call a
serpentine we have all these electron
shells are bound to each other in a long
string and that string we call the
serpentine the whole serpentine is
twirling in situ okay so that's what it
is so we're not talking about voltage
it's direct current or alternating
current we're talking about current
electricity okay
and uh you should be talking about
direction why talk about spinning
direction spin in that direction talk
about clockwise counterclockwise mother
nature then understands you see if you
say the the thing is turning clockwise
or the thing is turning counterclockwise
mother nature understands you but you
say direction some people say well is
that the north direction is it the south
direction in which direction are we
pointing
so don't use the word direction because
you're talking about orientation how
something is pointed or whatever now
talk about clockwise and
counterclockwise very simple don't talk
about positive or negative because we
have no idea what positive or negative
is no one has ever defined in physical
terms what positive and negative are
okay these are just labels that they put
in they're saying this one's different
than that one
and you could say this one's opposite to
that one and still we haven't learned
anything because we don't know what's
physically occurring at these terminals
but with clockwise and counterclockwise
straightforward and uh so just let me
one more time go through the voltage
thing so this one understands okay this
is voltage according to quantum
mechanics and what it is is um
what these people uh believe is that
little beads are moving along the wire
okay and what they do is they have them
moving a straight line when in fact they
know that these things spiral
and it turns out that they don't move
like we said the other day they say the
electrons really move very little almost
in situ and also spiraling because
they're spiraling and moving in situ
well that's giving us a clue what
electricity is really
and so the electrons don't really move
they're spiraling
and so you know if you put them together
well you end up with the rope model
which is this one you're saying what
we're saying here is that you know you
have all these serpentines made of
merged electron shells and they're
spinning around in situ and what we see
at the opposite ends is what we call
voltage which is just a clockwise and
counterclockwise uh
instigation or
you know you're essentially
triggering something to happen
in
in this case uh this is the simple
lead battery what we're saying is what's
happening there is there's a chemical
reaction that's causing this effect okay
simple you can see
past videos where i talked about it but
anyways the point here is that uh it's
different than electricity under the
rope model is simply the torsion in situ
of electron shells which are merged and
that's more or less how quantum
mechanics
describes it after you put them against
the wall first they show you this
beads rolling around then when you put
them against the wall they say well it's
not really the beads rolling around what
it really is that they move very little
and they move in circles locally
and so what they're doing is describing
really the rope model which is the
electron shells moving in situ but
before we can say that obviously we have
to figure out what an electron is
because either an electron is a little
bead
that moves around the atom
or it's what we say it is which is a
membrane a balloon that encapsulates
the uh
the atom the uh nucleus of the atom okay
okay so here uh continuing so that we
get to the final point here that we're
trying to make today uh here we have he
says uh stroboscope uh laser photography
we observe the electron
we observe the alarm we can't even
observe an atom he says we observe the
electron
and he says also he said we observe no
indication of invisible intangible ropes
so let's address that first and there
you see by the way the that's the
electron that was filmed supposedly by
the people in sweden one university in
sweden they claimed to the world oh we
were able to film an electron
what the hell are we staring at if we
can't even
see an electro we can't see an atom and
they saw an electron
and i'm sure they're going to see gluons
and quarks and whatever right yeah sure
so we can't see it but they filmed it
they see it that's an electron
my god and uh so let's go first with the
first issue there or the the one that uh
second issue i'm sorry the invisible and
intangible uh apparently this fellow um
you know he must be
uh english as a second language maybe
he's uh
uh uh one of these illegal ignorance
and so here it is let's let's explain
what these words mean okay invisible
not visible not perceptible by the eye
invisible fluid withdrawn from or out of
sight hidden again just in case that's
defined visible because if not visible
what do you mean by that well visible
that cannot be seen person perceptible
to the eye visible means that it can be
seen as perceptible to the eye invisible
means the opposite it cannot be seen
okay so uh yeah if it's an invisible
rope i don't know what you're doing
straining your eyes trying to see it
why are you straining your eyes you
can't see it because it's invisible
so what part don't you understand again
you know illegally ignorant uh maybe and
then we have intangible what is
intangible well it's not tangible that's
what it means intangible means not
tangible means what incapable of being
perceived by the sense of touch you
can't touch it
just in case you know tangible capable
of being touched so if you can touch it
it's called tangible if you can't touch
it it's called intangible and uh what is
touch to put hand finger etc on or on to
in contact with something
so
again i don't know what this fellow is
trying to do he's trying to touch or
see
that which is intangible and invisible
you know i don't understand that
why is he
breaking his head on something that
is untouchable unsealable and he says oh
i can't see or touch it no kid
tell me about it
okay uh but where does this take us well
it takes us to this to the size of the
electron okay
and it says it is concluded that the
diameter these this is from
our good old friend uh arthur compton a
hundred years now 1919 okay
and they tried to figure out what was
that diameter the size of the electron
and listen to the numbers that'll give
you a clue of how big an electron is
and maybe it'll give you a clue why we
can't see it and why uh this uh
who says you know we can observe in
and uh an electron with whatever uh uh
stroboscope or laser photography uh no i
don't think so not an electron and here
you have first uh arthur compton and he
says it is concluded that the diameter
of the electron is comparable in
magnitude with the wavelength of the
shortest
gamma rays using the best available
values for the wavelength and the
scattering by matter of hard x-rays and
gamma rays the radius of the electron is
estimated he's estimating 1919 okay this
is just an initial estimate okay as
about 2 times 10 to the minus 10
centimeter okay so this was his
conclusion at the time
what has happened since then well they
did a lot more experiments right a lot
of more calculations etc
this is out of the wikipedia today the
upper bound of the electron radius of 10
to the minus 18 meters can be derived
using the uncertainty relation in energy
just a calculation they've never seen it
they can't see it no no equipment will
ever see an electron but they're saying
okay look
we know at least that that's the upper
bound 10 to the minus 18 meters okay
because up to that point we can't see it
okay and then uh in coral we have all
these verses this is so funny because
you know everybody's an expert and it
turns out they all have different
opinions and nothing but
it has no structure even if you probe it
with a scope with a resolution of 10 to
the minus 18 meters great another guy
says all experiments done so far
show it to be point size
uh it has zero size that's what point
size means okay so how big is an
electron it's zero size
okay and they say that's according to
the experiments in other words they've
never seen one
and this fellow says let's let me put it
here so that we can see it as well it
says that
what they have been able to observe an
electron
and the last guy says in quantum scale
the scale in which electrons belong to
neither physical size nor mass do not
matter much
and i think he said it right in other
words they don't care because they can't
see it and they don't care anyways
it's it's it's not uh in their job
description the mathematicians to see it
okay that's not their job to draw it or
whatever they so they can give you
whatever nonsense they can tell you
whatever nonsense and get away with it
okay that's the issue because they don't
care mathematician doesn't care about
architecture about structure about
bodies he just wants calculations
numbers values that's what that's his
job
function okay so that's the problem he's
not a physicist he calls himself a
mathematical physicist but he's not a
physicist at all okay
okay and here we have
uh says uh atomic force microscope
microscopy we see atomic bonding not
only we see electron now we see the
bonds
uh the bonds is what
bonds to atom let alone molecules but
you can bond also
atoms and he's saying they can see the
bonds
man god's eyes or god's microscope i
don't know
and we are observing the effects of
vacuum energy
now you don't not only observe energy
which is a concept you're observing the
effects
of energy i guess he's observing the
real things that he can observe
which can be experimentally observed
yeah i mean you can
in experiments you can go to the lab and
see the visible tangible things maybe
right but you cannot see the invisible
and intangible things you know like
gravity whatever that is
the mediator of light whatever that is
the mediator of magnetism you know those
things you cannot see or touch for some
strange reason okay
and here's a
a prime example uh nitrogen atom that's
probably the best picture they ever got
of an atom
okay
and using atomic force microscope uh
this organization there they were able
to get a uh
an image
remember this is as you can see there
there they're pixels it's like they
construct the thing pixel by pixel okay
so that's what's happening here they're
they're going in there and with light
playing around with light with a
wavelength of light okay they were able
to build little by little this image
which is probably the best image we've
got of an atom supposedly in an atom on
top of a uh piece of uh
copper okay and that's a nitrogen atom
now a nitrogen atom is
at least 14 times as big as a hydrogen
atom it's uh you know you got
seven protons seven neutrons there
essentially right so you got 14 it's the
atomic weight 14 okay
and uh so the question is if if this is
the best we can see
is it possible to see this bond that
this guy says between two atoms between
two molecules the bond i mean what is a
bond okay and here you have them this is
the way they illustrate them okay uh you
see that they put all these carbon and
nitrogen and hydrogen
atoms and they they unite them or they
bind them with this bond
and you can see the hydrogen bond there
they put a a dotted line because they
don't know what it is
and you see in the in the carbon there
the carbon uh
atoms there are connected they just put
a little line
so where do you find these lines in the
standard model what are these bonds okay
and so this is the issue they put them
in there by hand but they but
you never find them in the standard
model and so you say what is this
hydrogen bond
i mean is it a physical entity is it a
stick is that what a bond is so if you
can't see an atom okay like this guy
there right or barely see it
how can you tell me that you're going to
see a an uh
an electron or even a bond that connects
to atoms in fact in many cases they say
the electrons are connected by a bond so
the bond is if you can't see the
electron let alone a bond and this guy's
talking about oh yeah we've seen them
we've
imaged them you know etcetera and he
really believes that you know that
they've seen electrons and bonds
and they've shown like uh that little
movie of the
electron blue electron you know waving
and so on
you know and they really buy it you can
sell them the uh empire state building
twice
okay so
for this we have to look at the electron
what is an electron well they say it's
an elementary point particle those are
the terms that they use for electrons
you look at the elementary particle or
fundamental particle and it says a
subatomic particle that is not composed
of other particles
so the buck stops there it's a particle
that's not comprised of anything smaller
meaning
that is the
uh
last particle
of quantum
and you know again the uh reporter at
the end of the room says uh what is it
made out of
and the guy says we'll give us more
money and we'll break it up and we'll
tell you what it's made out of the
electron is made out of the z particles
so all the
so so quantum mechanics has a is uh is
job security because all you need to do
is break up whatever particle
and you find a new particle and then
they say well what's that particle made
uh well give us more money and we'll
break it up and we'll tell you what
that's made out of and all they do is
you know stamp collecting they say the
electron is made out of the bees and if
you
smash the bees hard enough then those
are made out of a's or maybe out of z's
they give them just names and you they
keep going and going and going and going
down the line that's all they have
and so what is it stamp collecting we
have no explanation however how this
universe works but they keep inventing
all these particles you know the
so-called particle zoo
and right now they stopped at the
electron because it's so small they
can't even break that one up
okay so so it's like the end of the line
for quantum they can't see it they can't
break it up so what do we do now we stop
physics because these people
have reached the end of the line
and then a point particle what is that
an idealization of particles heavily
used in physics yeah unfortunately none
fizzy in mathematics maybe its defining
feature is that it lacks spatial
extension
an object that doesn't have spatial
extension
being dimensionless it does not take up
space
sounds like they're talking about
something that has no volume no no size
at all
a point particle is an appropriate
representation of any object whenever
its size shape and structure are
irrelevant in a given context
meaning that that's what the
mathematicians use all the time they use
words such as energy field mass and so
on because they don't care about the
objects they care about all these
concepts so you're never going to find
uh a physical object in mathematical
physics all you're going to find is all
these concept mathematical concepts
which they converted into
objects they can criticize the concrete
size them or whatever it's called
they reified and that's what happened
they reified concepts
okay
so here we have it um
go on the other side give me a second
here where'd he go
okay here you have the
electron according to uh
another fella you know he's got a
different notion of what the electron is
he doesn't think of it as a particle
he's trying to explain to you
what an electron is and this is what he
goes through he says electron is in
quantum mechanics having wave function
oh my god the wave function again okay
this describes the probability
distribution of the electron
so we have a electron it has a wave
function meaning a wave function tells
you the distribution of the electron
within the wave function
wave function supposedly is this region
and you're going to find the electron in
that region which more or less you get
the picture right at the bottom there
okay and so it says
uh continuously says how likely you are
to find it in a particular place okay
quantum mechanics means that nothing in
the universe knows where the electron is
inside the wave function before one
looks for it
well that's strange you would think that
uh every object in the universe has a
location
irrespective of whether anyone's looking
for it
i mean the does
an electron
acquire a location
only when god looks at it and when god's
not looking it doesn't have a location
what do you mean by that
it has to have a location at some point
every object in the universe must have a
location
whether you're looking at it or not it's
got nothing to do with the observer
and again that's why we take the
observer out of the picture there are no
observers in science all objects exist
and have a location irrespective of the
observer the observer is only a question
of knowledge not an issue of uh
of where the object really is on its own
okay hopefully you have a location
irrespective of whether anyone's looking
at you and hopefully adam every atom in
your body has a location
right
and hopefully every electron within
every atom has a location
and to say that you know all we have to
do is take a snapshot of the universe
stop the universe
and look at your atoms boy they had
better have a location with respect to
each other for a given cross-section of
time
so don't tell me that they don't have a
location what is an object that doesn't
have a location it's an object that
doesn't exist that's what it is because
what's existence object with location
so okay so
paul says he again he talks about no
nose knowledge right the way function of
electrons around an atomic nucleus sort
of look like an inflated balloons like
inflated balloons and there he's got a
picture of it okay well that sounds a
lot or looks a lot like what we have in
the rope model so let's look at the rope
model of that same water molecule there
and here it is okay that's what our
molecule looks like yeah we're talking
about balloons
so their their famous water molecule
yeah we think it's just a balloon bunch
of balloons that are bound to each other
they're merged the shells the electron
shells the electron membranes electron
balloons they're merged with each other
and that's what an atom is and in this
case a molecule
so you know we do have a solution for it
all we have to do is get rid of the
notion of discrete particles that's it
as long as you do it with particles
you're negatively going to figure this
out and that's what they've been doing
for the last 10 000 years okay
okay so here are my conclusions okay
for today
not that we stopped on the subject okay
but conclusions qm quantum mechanics
electrons uh says it's equal to no size
it's a point particle okay
uh it has no subcomponents it's an
elementary particle meaning it's it's
not made of anything okay so it is
an indivisible particle
and they would say up till today
tomorrow we don't know maybe we get a
big atom smasher electron smasher and we
can tell you what it's made out of but
right now we we can't figure it out
through experiments so we're going to
say it's a elementary particle not made
of
smaller constituents okay
but the other guy says electron is
really a wave function or where you can
find the electron within the wave
function whatever that means i mean you
know
what is that it's just telling you that
it's in this region
okay so i don't care if it's in that
region hopefully all my electrons right
are in this region
right and if and and we could stop the
universe for a second get a cross
section of time i'm sure god could go in
there and pinpoint where all my
electrons are hopefully because
nothing's moving at that moment in time
except him
right or maybe electron every electron
with respect to him but he can more or
less pinpoint every electron so
hopefully every electron in the universe
has
a location at a given cross-section of
time
okay
zero time right
uh so what's a wave function well a
function is an equation a formula so
what are they talking about they're
saying it's in this region
and we can calculate it we can calculate
what the region looks like again
meaningless we don't care where it's at
what are we going to do with it what is
an electron is it a bead we haven't
shown that yet
uh so
so far the quantum electron is not an
object not a thing until they
can tell you or define it as such as a
thing point to it but if they're going
to say it's zero dimension has no volume
no size what are you going to point to
you know point to nothing
you're pointing to space
vacuum
and uh
yeah the electron according to quantum
mechanics just a mathematical concept
that's what they deal with so whenever
you ask a question of
objects whenever you ask a question of
how something works and they're going to
use the electron they're introducing a
concept and they're going to
pitch it to you as a physical object
that's where the problem is
and um
under the rope model very simple uh the
electron is a membrane it encapsulates
the proton
and that's going to be the subject of my
next
lecture
okay
so let's get rid of this one and let's
go with the questions and comments that
people made since last time see if we
can get them up here okay here's the
first one father says uh if earth
if is if earth is rolling around on
space time shouldn't everything on the
surface of earth be crushed black
absolutely you got that one right in
fact i've got it in uh in my website you
stupid relativist.com there you have
bill being crushed by space time between
space time and the earth because if the
earth
uh rolls around space time and we we're
assuming space time has to be rigid more
or less because it's preventing the
earth from flying out of space out of
the
solar system and the earth more or less
runs or you know it doesn't
jiggle back and forth it runs on a
smooth course that means that space time
is so rigid that
the earth doesn't make uh you know it's
not like it's rolling on a canvas or
anything it's really rolling on a rigid
surface under the under uh
general relativity it has to because uh
you know the earth doesn't jiggle back
and forth and so you know if uh if it
rolls around on a rigid surface and i'm
on the surface i guess uh i should be
squashed to death you know i should be
able to move
and so yeah this guy is right
under the under general relativity
you should be squashed because
uh the explanation is that the earth is
in direct contact with space-time and
it's space-time that's preventing the
earth from flying out of the solar
system that's the physical
interpretation
and then they roll their eyes and say oh
but you took it literally yeah what am i
supposed to do i'm supposed to explain
how the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
the mechanism please explain the
mechanism if you're going to use the
canvas analogy what was the analogy for
if you're going to deny it at the end of
your presentation say oh by the way you
shouldn't take that literally then what
was i supposed to do
with your your so-called analogy
okay uh another fella i asked or says he
says if i can hit him with a tree it's
an object
so he wants to prove the word object
he's going to use
uh
anything he's saying
if it's an object if i can hit him with
it
and so yeah we have a problem because it
means uh that if you can't hit the uh
klingon on the other side of the
universe with your
bat baseball bat then until you hit him
it's not an object
okay
all these uh
contradictions or these irrationalities
that these people run into simply
because they don't follow what they're
saying they don't even understand what
they're saying
electricity has mass okay it's 3d
electricity is 3d
that makes it an object okay so we have
3d
electricity please draw it if it's 3d
should be able to illustrate it right
make a picture of electricity for us
what does this 3d electricity look like
i mean is it like a cube is it like a
sphere
you know is it like a
gorilla or an elephant or a rock i mean
please please illustrate electricity
okay once we see a picture we'll know
what you're talking about
and in thinking all shapes our objects
is ridiculously irrational
yeah and so uh
all he has is uh
opinions unsubstantiated opinions and i
think he continues here a little bit he
says uh an object is an identifiable
collection of matter he got that out of
the
the i think wikipedia which may be
constrained by an identify identifiable
boundary and may move as a unit or
translational rotation in
three-dimensional space yeah all he's
doing is parroting uh copy-paste you
know in fact i put that on there my
criticism i was put here
uh copy paste opinion unsubstantiated
argument definition
yeah what these people do is they
tremble because the definition of the
word object destroys all religions and
it destroys their religion so you know
they're concerned about it and so he
says to say all shapes are objects is
completely observed pseudoscience cult
beliefs uh
yeah but see the problem it's the other
way around you have a belief because you
have no way of substantiating what you
just said all you have is a belief and
that's it you don't have any more so all
you're doing is parroting the
establishment and you don't even know
what you're parodying okay so
copy paste doesn't do it you got to be
able to get in the ring and defend your
definitions if you can't defend them
you're done you're you've got no case
it's just as simple as that
uh another fellow along the same line
says object that which you can imagine
or draw
anything you can imagine or draw are
objects because anything you can imagine
or draw must have shape or it would be
impossible to imagine or draw them
well what you have there is again the
the definition of the word object
destroys our religion these guys are
absolutely
you know
drives them up the walls okay so
uh here we have a situation that plays
extreme devil's advocate yeah that's
what he's doing there that's all
uh you know saying that you have a that
you drawing is a definition no that's an
experiment okay you're doing something
it's a bet it's a challenge i bet you
can't draw yeah i can draw i'll i'll bet
you a hundred dollars that's a it's a
it's just a bed it's an experiment not a
definition okay it's a it's a challenge
and you can't use your definition in
physics this drawing thing okay because
we gotta wait till you draw it
okay
and then if there's a single object in
the universe we have yet no artist
okay so we have the object there and the
question is
uh no one drew it it's just a it's just
a
i don't know a cube or a sphere it's
there that's the universe we have
suddenly we come up against it i don't
care if you draw it or not the object
was there before you appear
and so the question is is that an object
or do you have do we have to wait till
you draw it
okay so the object is already there
before you the observer ever came into
being okay
and if you are quadriplegic uh you can't
draw does that mean you know pluto stops
being an object
yeah you know no longer an object
because now you can't
draw you don't have hands to draw you're
you know stephen gawking or something
and then if you just lost your head okay
which you obviously have you know
chicken without a head
was a sword you were holding still an
object despite that you can no longer
imagine it
i mean you have no no head now you can't
imagine it
uh probably not not be able to grab a
pencil right or anything to draw so you
can't imagine or draw it does the sword
that you you still have in your hand is
is that an object or not or does it stop
being an object because now you can't
see draw or imagine it
okay
so again no observers in science no
observers in physics uh drawing besides
is a verb
and objects precede verbs you need
objects to do verbs
in physics so
again devil's advocacy that's okay no
problem i i've got no problem with
devil's
advocacy extreme devil's advocacy no
problem
but you know uh if you got nothing more
well you're going to learn the hard way
that you know you're going to look back
on the definition of shape okay you
can't avoid it and again the issue
the bottom line is that we either go
with shape or we see touch which is what
the mathematical establishment uses
right now that's the bottom line okay so
we either go with shape or c touch and
hopefully we can't go with c touch
because objects precede verbs and you
need two verbs to do a c touch okay
uh two objects i'm sorry to do see touch
okay uh falsettos how many atoms in the
universe whoa i don't know and he says
10 to the 82nd power he goes through all
this calculation and it says at 10 to
the 82nd power minus 1 multiplied blah
blah blah blah par we wouldn't even be
able to view atomic bonding
too many ropes would be in the way
c touch that's what's got these people
poor folks they they suffer with a c
touch so they say well how many ropes
are there well how many atoms are there
are there many atoms we call them many
is many a good word a very quantitative
uh very accurate word you know we have
many atoms and we have many ropes and
the ropes are intangible invisible
okay and so we can put many ropes in the
same place at the same time
and so this is what drives them up the
walls how can how can we have so many
ropes criss-crossing and so we wouldn't
see anything no because you can't see
the ropes so you're going to see the
atom right through the ropes
you're not going to see the the ropes
because your rope the one from your eye
goes directly to the other atom it
doesn't go to a rope
it goes from atom to adam not from adam
the rope so you can't see the rope
because there's no connection between
the atoms that allow you to see right
to the ropes
atoms are connected to atoms not the
ropes
so he doesn't understand that
no problem there right
okay uh here we have another phone he
says
is tension a property of the rope
yeah
uh or do the atom somehow cause the rope
to be under tension
well uh the whole universe is under
tension
in the sense that everything is moving
in and tightening it constantly so we're
pulling on an atom that's pulling on
another atom that's pulling on another
atom at the same time that the atoms are
sliding remember
the you got to try to conceptualize this
and you have atoms vibrating and moving
along the ropes at the same time that
the rope is constantly under tension
between any two atoms
so the rokin the atom can only slide
along the rope but the rope essentially
is always under tension between any two
atoms because it's under tension
everywhere in the universe all we have
is atoms just moving along that tension
okay that's what the speed of light is
little c
at least in this side of the universe
maybe on another side of the universe
the slack is different maybe that's
where they you know give in because i'm
sure that all these atoms in the
universe all these galaxies are moving
with respect to each other and so
there's got to be some slack somewhere
okay but what i'm saying is a single
thread throughout every atom in the
universe it's a different universe than
the one i imagined by mathematical
physics and so yeah you gotta look at
that and try to conceptualize it try to
visualize what we're saying here okay
if all atoms are physically
interconnected they can slide along the
ropes meaning they eat into the ropes
because the atom is made of those same
threads that in which that also make up
the ropes
so
you know a fellow was asking the other
day saying we have uh how can the
rope pull on an atom it doesn't pull in
that sense in fact there is no pull it's
that the atom is made of the same
threads that the rope is made out of
when the atom slides through a rope the
uh the threads go around the one go
through the center the other one around
the atom
so the atom is eating into the rope like
you know
like you would be if you open up a rope
that's it
more or less like that so it's always
under tension but at the same time it's
moving
that's why you know light is independent
of the motion motion of the source the
source is made out of atoms
but you can move it but none of the
atoms are pushing on the rope it's
sliding through the rope eating into the
rope and so that's all you're doing
and and the signal is always in front of
you so you can never catch up with a
signal because you are moving into the
signal into the rope which is dissolving
into your body which is the atom
so that's that's how the universe is now
you can explain light under that
mechanism now you can see why light is
independent of the motion of the source
one and why the speed of light is always
a constant because it it only trades uh
frequency for wavelength in other words
number of links and the size of the
links right one for the other
and uh and
uh
yeah essentially you know that's
essentially those main points now we can
explain those those features of light
okay why the atom eats into the rope and
doesn't push on the rope or doesn't you
don't have to add the speed of light to
the motion of the atoms
on the one hand and on the other way the
speed of light is constant okay
both essentially two sides of the same
coin
and um
fellow says if there was only one robe
with their b tension
uh
well there is not only one rope there's
only one thread okay so to talk about
one rope i don't know what what
you know
visualization you have there uh there's
a rope between two atoms so you can't
have just one rope like without any
atoms or or nothing like that you got to
conceptualize the whole thing the whole
picture
uh and if it's the atom doing
so then how okay and he says if tension
means no one wins the tug of war then
shouldn't the pen float mid air instead
of falling to the ground
so let me illustrate that once more okay
i've illustrated a couple times one more
time just in case other people have same
questions okay here we have uh
an astronaut at different locations with
respect to the center of the earth
and what we have is tension along a rope
not along all ropes at the same time in
other words all the ropes are under
tension but what you have is different
number of ropes independent ropes which
have different tensions at different
locations okay so you have in other
words the distance between the astronaut
and the center of the earth
is what changes the number of ropes so
all you have is different number of
ropes they're all under tension okay the
speed of light along each one of those
ropes is little c
uh 300 000 kilometers per second but
what you have is more ropes that's all
you have you have differences in ropes
that's all you have that's what gravity
is that's why the uh pen would not stay
in mid-air because it drifts and as it
changes its location as it gets closer
to the earth the number of ropes changes
the tension on the rope is always the
same and one rope on any given row but
the tension is the same tension doesn't
change
what changes is the location of the
astronaut with respect to the center of
the earth and what's changing is the
number of ropes that are acting
individually that's the issue okay
along the same lines of person ass
uh
get this here
[Music]
says uh there's something redundant in
that formula for gravity okay
and again we see it there on the side
okay so i'll leave that up there and
phil says um if weight equals mass in
other words if one kilogram of gold in
weight is also one kilo of gram of
golden mass then we would have the same
value on both sides of the equation
something is wrong with that
uh
the issue here is that we're we're
getting confused with the notion of mass
of mathematic mathematical physics which
is weight so that mass there mass 1 mass
2 right those two masses are essentially
weights they're putting weight in there
and because they're turning that mass
into a value such as kilograms that's
what you're going to be putting in there
you're not going to be putting what we
put in uh in under the rope model which
is physics you're not going to put the
number of ropes there you're going to
say you're not going to say oh there's 1
trillion ropes in mass 1 and 2 trillion
ropes in mass 2. nobody calculates
anything like that but that's what mass
is it's the number of independent ropes
that
converge upon atoms because you have a
certain number of atoms so
that distance squared determines how
many ropes there are okay that that
distance is important but it's important
to know that distance what that distance
is it's not distance traveled
the mathematicians what they when they
look at that little distance squared
there the d squared
that distance they say well they're
they're going to put meters or
kilometers or miles that's the value
they're going to put in there that's
those are the units how did they get
those miles how did they get those
meters or kilometers well the way they
got it is they they paced from one mass
to the other mass and they say okay
there's one kilometer between these two
masses
that's how they figure these things out
but that's wrong because that distance
there is not distance traveled meaning
it wasn't it's not a calculated value
that you do by pacing and saying okay i
counted so many meters that's not what
it is what that distance is just
separation between the two objects
that's what that distance represents
there is no there is no itinerary
there's no measurement there it's just a
separation between two masses
the more separation there is the fewer
independent ropes you have between the
two masses the closer the two masses are
which is the case there was like for
example the 100 kilogram that the
astronaut weighs there on the right well
the closer he is the more ropes there
are acting independently each one with
the same tension okay because it's
little c little c is a measure of the
tension on the rope that's why it's a
constant all we're changing a frequency
for wavelength meaning number of links
uh versus link length
and what you have is that astronaut has
a
certain number of ropes at 100 kilograms
less fewer ropes at 50 kilograms and
even fewer ropes at 25 kilograms let
alone at what we call infinity you know
at a long distance the long distance all
those ropes essentially
uh blend into one
and they act as one it's like a single
coaxial
and so yeah
the problem here that this file has is
that we have two masses but those masses
are weights in mathematical physics
that's the way they figure those out so
we have weight is equal to weight times
weight divided by distance squared and
so he says well kind of redundant you
know and you could switch that around
maybe and say you know what's mass well
mass is weight
because how do you figure uh man how do
you figure the mass of something what
did this other fellow say you put it on
a scale so you put it on a scale you
weigh it and now you know what that mass
is and so you could also replace that
little w there with a
mass okay instead of weight you put mass
and
you would be figuring out the force
of the number of atoms uh on earth you
know in other words the gravity how
gravity pulls on on that mass and so
yeah so that's why he says it's
redundant it's like we're going around
in circles here and he's totally right
about that you know uh what you have
here is uh a problem with definitions
where they haven't defined
uh the mathematicians haven't defined
what weight is and what mass is they
haven't distinguished one from the other
very clearly okay and this is this is
where the problem is that
uh definition what is mass is mass the
quantity of matter meaning one trillion
atoms or is it one kilogram and until
you resolve that
uh you know unambiguously
you gotta
resolve that
we need to know what we're talking about
we talking about quantity of matter are
we talking about a measurement of the
quantity of matter meaning you put it on
a scale you weigh it
right because you're going to weigh it
for example here on earth right and
you're going to get a weight
and they say well no it's not weight
because if you take it on the moon it
has a different weight
but the mass is the same meaning the
number of atoms hasn't changed meaning
the number of atoms is the same meaning
you got to talk about how many trillions
of atoms the object has and not about
what the weight of it is you can't put
that in in a measurement you can't put
that in kilograms you got to state that
in number of atoms you gotta say look
here on earth it's got one trillion
atoms and if you take it to the moon it
still has one trillion atoms
then we all understand the number of
atoms has not changed everybody's on the
same page but if you say look it weighs
differently here and weighs differently
there
but the mass is the same
well what do you then why why are you
weighing the mass if the mass is going
to change as soon as you take it to the
moon
and you say it has a different weight
now yeah but
but how did you determine it on earth
well you weigh it they're saying they're
putting it on a scale and weighing it so
we're they're running around in circles
that's all they're doing with the word
mass and weight they never figured that
out in 400 years since the days of
newton okay
okay with that i'll see you next time i
think it's on wednesday and hopefully
we'll see you then we're going to be
talking about the proton
okay
so we'll see you then